tá gravando rapaz sinto agora em um
lugar muito especial pra mim sic é
palmeira do piauí aqui que nasci e me
criei um bem para esse matuto e aí
galera que assistir o canal todo bom
vocês quantas vezes já falei isso esse
ano ela era tô estou feliz pra caramba
estou muito muito feliz pra muita gente
2013 foi um ano ruim né
sei lá por conta de qualquer
acontecimento da vida da pessoa até
acontecer alguma coisa na família dela
pode ter sido reprovado na escola pode
ter perdido a virgindade por negão sei
não sei mas pra mim era 2013 foi um ano
do [ __ ] você que é novo no canal você
não deve saber mas já batia muito nessa
tecla do youtube a vida inteira sabe até
que um dia um vídeo meu chamado alô voto
reprovado estourou passou de 5 milhões
de visualizações e aí meu canal ganhou
muito escrito e se tornou o maior canal
do nordeste eu falei [ __ ] agora agora
vai à noite onde a galera começou a
mensagem isso que aconteceu com o canal
estou conseguindo ver os vídeos e passa
pela quando eu fui ver a galera no canal
tinha sido excluído do youtube eu falei
vai se se não deu certo agora é porque
não dá pra dar certo nunca e aí eu falei
vou parar mas eu comecei a receber
mensagens de tanta gente cá tanta gente
falando que eu não deveria parar que eu
tinha uma coisa diferente dos outros não
era mensagem de gente que passava o dia
inteiro na internet queria ver vídeos em
mim só pra pra ficar de boa fé a
mensagem de gente que precisava de uma
alegria só chegava do trabalho chegava
da escola precisava de uma alegria
alguma coisa que fizesse r pelo menos
por cinco minutos e é o que eu faço mas
nem eu falei vai agora vai estabelecer a
meta galera de até o fim do ano ter 100
mil inscritos só sabe que o motivo da
minha felicidade entrei no canal e ver
quantos inscritos têm aí vai ter aquela
galera que vai falar-se nossa não quer
dizer que você está muito feliz que você
conseguiu 300 mil inscritos no youtube
nosso nossa que coisa você quer a pessoa
que não está feliz por mim dela ela não
conhece o windows um garçom no ela não
conhece o windows o que sai às sete
horas da noite voltava 4 horas da manhã
à noite inteira correndo pra lá e pra cá
carregando bandejas para ganhar 65 não
tem nada a ver com um número grande de
inscreverem a ver você firmou um
compromisso de conseguir um certo tipo
de coisa
você conseguiu um triplo e quem faz
crescer é você e eu agradeço muito a
você que fala assim
cara esse vídeo é bom a i mostra pra
amigo olha que esse vídeo aqui
meu amigo me conhece mostra um amigo
dele e assim vai criando um ciclo e as
pessoas vão conhecendo o meu trabalho
uma grande parte desses inscritos que eu
tenho uma grande parte das pessoas que
me assistem vem pra essa pessoa que
mostra o vídeo para outra pessoa muito
obrigado a você que mostra outra pessoa
eu estou feliz pra carai vem se você tem
alguma página se você tem algum perfil
alguma coisa e você publicou um vídeo
meu lar cara muito obrigado porque isso
contribuiu muito com meu canal prefeito
você estiver pensando que o facebook tem
o quê
sem amigos e se você compartilhar você
não vai me ajudar a ficar puramente
enganado tudo o que você fizer vai me
ajudar o comentário que você deixe me
ajuda o joinha que você dá me ajuda
quando você se inscreve você me ajuda
quando você me segue no twitter do
facebook aqui no youtube no instagram
tudo ajuda porque uma coisa leva a outra
galera todas as minhas redes sociais ao
público eu vi você nunca vai perder se
você seguir nas redes sociais
aqui a proposta aqui na descrição do
vídeo que você quer ver tem muita gente
que questiona o amigo que fala assim a
cara por que você gosta dos vídeos e
meninas não vejo graça nos vídeos e
menininha porque você ainda assistir as
meninas pessoa não gosta de mim porque
eu faço os vídeos impressa internet as
pessoas gostam de mim é porque eu tenho
muitos seguidores nas pessoas gostam de
mim porque nos meus vídeos e representa
a parte louca delas têm medo de mostrar
pro mundo como é que você vai saber como
é que você sabe disso como é que você
vai saber disso assistir assisti aos
vídeos eu quero saber se esses mais de
80 vídeo já enviei no canal se um se
pelo menos 1 você não se identificar
nesse vídeo que você se identificou e
mostrar essa parte sua que você tem medo
de mostrar pulso e esse também é um
compromisso ou firmar com vocês nesse
canal vou sempre está representando à
parte louca de vocês uma coisa que eu
sempre faço está sempre mostrando quem
eu sou de verdade em qualquer rede
social não ficar mentindo dizendo que eu
sou uma pessoa
ae enfim quem nem entendo que as pessoas
seguirem nunca tem muita gente que chega
pra mim falar nada sei o que me segue aí
se você for humilde porque têm a venda
de lá sei o que o faz aí o cara chega
pra mim no bate-papo assim consumir o
vídeo aí galera muito obrigado mesmo
vocês me assistir muito obrigado mesmo
pra cá eu sei que um dia talvez vocês
possam abusar a gente a falar até se
fazendo de coitadinhos vai pensando
pequeno tem o que não é isso não é
exceção natural das pessoas mesmo dia
ela pode não gostar mais um dia ela pode
querer mais assistir eu quero dizer que
se um dia você não quiser mais me
assiste se você abusar se você perder a
vontade
muito obrigado por todo esse tempo você
passou me assistindo e me ajudou o cara
tá me ajudando a viver de uma coisa que
eu gosto você está inscrito e eu conheço
muita gente eu conheço muita gente que
está desde o começo comigo muita gente
mesmo não vou dizer o nome das pessoas
porque enfim né porque sei lá pode ser
que eu esqueci de algum aqui agora mas
lembra depois vai ficar fechado eu
queria agradecer muito a todo mundo
quebra diz el diego ouvindo suricato
seboso que é um cara que já tive o
prazer de conhecer pessoalmente gente
boa papo agora esse gabriel oliveira no
canal putz fé e me deu 11 jan parou
muito com o meu canal foi excluído por
acho que sem ele
meu canal 11 era o que é hoje agradecer
caio oliveira também toda a chafurdar em
si leonan plymouth av
moacir saulo joão josé moisés todo mundo
acha acordar e fechou a rodada é grande
em seu nome todo chafurdar eu mude jump
me prefeitura câmbio lucas o canal as
caraíbas é que é isso não iremos uso que
eu amo de paixão vou casar maria cláudia
canal do pascal todo mundo e agradecer
também ao brian fixa é você que não sabe
caro banho fita e tem uma história muito
louca eu resolvi ajudar e aí você que
não conhece o bairro feito e já apareceu
em vários vários vários vídeos meus e
não deve ter visto deve ter percebido o
vídeo do dia dos pais
ele que fez a mãe no vídeo pop sem ele
que faz a mulher que muda muito na pop
sem sair comigo andando a pelo camb no
vídeo do como eu me sinto quando vou
comer chega visita ele é o meu amigo
muitas vezes não divulguei o canal dele
porque porque eu estava tentando é dada
um amparo pra ele
antes dele antes de ele começar a
crescer tinha muita gente pensava se a
ue não quer que o canal do bahrain
cresça com medo de ele passar dele
alguma coisa assim nada vê nada a ver
não tem nada a ver é porque eu como eu
tive um boom na minha vida quando eu
estava não tinha nenhum vídeo bombacha e
aí o vídeo bombou eu meio que não
consegui me dar
eu meio que não consegui administrar
direito aquele sabe assim não conseguir
responder às pessoas não conseguia fazer
nada e tal e aí com medo de que isso
aconteceu também com ele eles
impressionasse com muita gente falando
com ele tal eu optei por deixa eu optei
por botar ele pra aparecer e participar
nos meus vídeos assim pra ele se é
administrando devagarzinho aquilo tudo
devagarzinho para ser melhor o canal
dele foi crescendo muito por conta de
não derrotar ajudando não derrotar
divulgando mas sim por trabalho bem
feito que é isso que eu gosto é gosto no
canal cresce porque o trabalho dele é
bem feito não porque alguém está
ajudando ele acrescentando agora quero
deixar o meu agradecimento ao black me
ajudou para a [ __ ] e ainda me ajuda
sempre que eu preciso e eu quero que
você se você puder mas se você quiser
você se interessar
você se inscreva no canal dele que é
esse canal aqui ó é só você clicar aqui
e você já vai diretamente para o canal
dele vai abrir outra aba não vai parar o
vídeo tá vai abrir outra aba se você
clicar aqui
você vai se inscrever no canal do bairro
tenho certeza que se você gosta dos meus
vídeos você vai gostar do vídeo dele
porque é basicamente o mesmo estilo
honra [ __ ] 2003 foi [ __ ] vem foi [ __ ] é
obrigado obrigado você está obrigado de
coração do fundo do coração é um
agradecimento de fim de ano especial de
fim de ano do canal não é uma coisa do
fundo do coração - sabe quando você está
feliz consigo nem quando se fica feliz
você fica realizado
a meta agora você sabe que a meta agora
é outro a meta agora é um milhão e 500
mil não é um milhão ambição aqui ó
sucesso subiu à cabeça humildade acabou
não tem mais agora 1 milhão a dominar o
mundo do youtube a 1 do tempo eu fiz
várias parcerias também com que fizerem
o canal crescesse também que estão a
crescer essa câmera que é nova ficando
aqui foi com o dinheiro que vocês me
ajudaram
vocês me ajudar vocês vão ajudar vocês
me ajudar e agora preciso de um
microfone o sensei sabe não sei se sabe
mas eu gravo salal oi oi e de casa
a funcionar assim aqui o áudio e até a
cangaço me ajudou muito a cangaço essa
aqui ó essas lusa só sossega o facho me
apeguei não ar marina todas essas coisas
que têm aids as buscas de temática
nordestina cangaço www.gaz.com.br a meu
deus agora é a hora da propaganda agora
dormir achando sei o que é engraçado que
vocês querem que a gente presa e vocês
querem que a gente não ganha de ninguém
que seja quem tem dinheiro para equipar
pra contar câmara amarelos ainda não
sentaram no meio da rua e gente grande e
para viver a gente tem dinheiro para
pagar a luz não pagar a água pra pagar
energia aluguel se acomode que criou
como luz e de 90 eu não sei mas tem
gente que se ofende quando a pessoa
começa a ganhar algum tempo e dinheiro
galera vamos ser assim e quando tem uma
propaganda não é para o chá não é porque
pra gente precisa de ouvir ver e ilógico
também que quando estiver ganhando muito
dinheiro eu vou ter que ganhar mais
dinheiro pela guarda futuro e acho que
eu tenho que 30 anos tem 18 anos e eu
tenho uma vida toda pela frente é
começar a ganhar dinheiro é guardado
chegado onde eu fazer uma faculdade
alguma coisa outra parceria que eu
fechei muito boa mesmo foi da canon e
que todo mundo faca não está dominando
youtube sabe o que é inteligência nenhum
futuro está na internet pode não ser no
youtube youtube é pagar o bug do satanás
aí acabar mas se acabar nós vamos a
outro e vamos fazer em outro lugar eu
não é chega então se você quiser visitar
a canon é o primeiro link na descrição
do vídeo se você comprar qualquer coisa
com o meu cupom que está lá é só copiar
e colar você tem 10% de desconto em
qualquer que você for comprar qualquer
coisa foi com gripe a é isso ai eu
queria que você comentasse aqui embaixo
qual foi a melhor coisa que já aconteceu
em 2003 eu não quero que você comenta a
melhor ea pior dessa vez não porque é
final de ano é hora de saber da notícia
ruim não né negócio não é a melhor quero
que a melhor coisa que você que
aconteceu com você no m3 e comente aqui
embaixo e outra coisa vocês são [ __ ] já
falei vocês me ajudaram pra [ __ ] já
falei agora quero que você me ajuda
àquele jovem de fim de ano quero que
você fez parte da minha caminhada você
fez parte dessa caminhada que vem lá de
quando eu era garçom de quando o [ __ ]
quando era garçom cara eu já fazia vídeo
a galera falar o quanto faz um vídeo na
internet e ficava na merda agora imagina
agora que eu vou no shopping a galera
tira foto
a potycabana galera tira foto vão em
palmeira ea galera tira foto pois é [ __ ]
não tem nada a ver com você formosinho
com a sede das pessoas não querem sair
você sabe que o reconhecimento de seu
trabalho chegando em todo lugar cara e é
assim negão é do nordeste punição
daqueles junho para saber que você me
acompanhou e se você quer que eu cresça
mais ainda ea meta agora 1 milhão
ai beijo na boca fia nos vemos em 2014
com os melhores vídeos vocês já viram na
internet tudo entenda sua vida
normalmente estão dizendo estamos
passando se momento segue no twitter
segue no facebook segue no instagram se
inscreve no youtube já 1